the gyro can experience I've always felt
like that's one of the things in New
York has a large advantage over Los
Angeles is interaction people are
constantly on the subway and walking on
the streets with everybody of all
different classes all different
backgrounds and I think that's really
good I think it's good - yeah it's the
contact hypothesis right like if you
like if kids grow up with leave you had
a black friend growing up like since you
were you know three four you you won't
never inure you would never think to be
racist like it's just one of those
things it's like early contact with
different people and it's the same with
that's what I feel about ideas - early
contact with different ideas really
helps and that's that's I don't know I
kind of devoted my life to to that call
it's almost you know Daryl Davis's yes
of course I was at that conference that
that he was speaking at we were speaking
at the same conference and that's the
conference that Darrell Davis was called
neo-nazi that someone called him a
neo-nazi yeah yeah how do they how
because we explain to people who he is
if you didn't listen to the podcast that
I did with a Darrell Davis as a musician
and he was doing some shows at this
country-western bar and met some people
from the Klan and through just
communicating with them and being
friendly with them over a period of many
months he got them to quit they quit the
Klan on their own you can even request
it and then over the course of several
years he's gotten more than 200 people
to leave the Klan leave neo-nazi
organizations and he they give him their
robes and their flags and he brought
them all in here and he's a
inspirational human being very much so
but he essentially was reinforcing what
you were saying that these people were
never around anyone like one of the guys
that he met initially was saying I've
never had a drink with a black man
before and he's like how's that possible
he's like I'm in the Klan and he's like
I've never I've never had a drink with a
black man and so he's like this is the
first time ever having a drink with a
black man like making this big deal out
of it and then eventually
I was going to his house and eating
dinner with them and hanging out with
them and and then the guys like I can't
do this anymore
like why am I on the clan when he quit
Wow and he quit just from Daryl being
this really friendly articulate
brilliant guy who clearly didn't fit
their narrative of what they thought
they were racist depiction of what a
black man is right right
so the incident that happened was this
group called mythos Milwaukee had
organized a conference called me what
what missus missus yeah that was the
name of the group but they were kind of
like a Sekulow so in the Methodist
believe that Jesus Christ was eight like
he didn't really exist as a historical
figure that's what a mythos is but in
any case it is it's a secular group that
put on a conference and we've been doing
that for years and they had a long side
you know people like sargon of akkad you
know count dank euler the guy who taught
his pug to do that yeah yeah so these
people all came for a conference and so
was Darrell Davis and you know it was it
was a good it was a bunch of people but
on on the spec on on on the political
spectrum basically and it was about
promoting discourse civil dialogue that
kind of thing and Ino was there as well
so basically because you know after when
the conference was happening and and and
Tifa kind of found out about it they
started protesting the conference they
they called the the comp the venue to
basically you know get it cancelled they
said it was a neo-nazi rally Klan really
ironically you know the greatest irony
was that that Gerald Davis was there and
he got tainted as well so I started
calling this the political one-drop rule
where it's like kind of what happened to
you if you are associating or talking to
somebody that or just a whole range of
people like normal distribution of
people you will be tainted by the most
right-wing person you know that you're
in orbit with that's just how it goes
and that's what happened to Darrell so
when we have the after party to the
conference and Kiefer was gathered
outside the bar the pitman New Jersey
people
simple was there to the pitman New
Jersey people had police had to
stationed themselves outside of the bar
and you know they were kind of
protecting this event it's it's
ridiculous because you know yes you
might find sergeant's politics
objectionable but why is everybody who's
associated we know what the conference
also lumped in with this and why is the
response that this needs police
protection it's just we're just talking
about it it doesn't make any sense
no this desire to shut down speech is
very dangerous and it's very stupid it's
childish and it's this thing that it
gets it just gets reinforced in that
culture that this you know the culture
of either ante for people that support
NT but they don't understand the
consequences of shutting down speech you
think that you're just gonna shut down
speech and D platform people that have
marginally offensive views and the
problem with that is first of all you
close the door for them to be influenced
in a positive way or for other people to
learn from them being influenced in a
positive way right and second of all the
way to shut down ideas is not stop the
person from talking it's to combat those
ideas with better ideas and then
everyone around them gets to see the
discourse when you have these debates
online and people discuss these things
online it benefits millions of people
yeah when you shut that down it benefits
nobody but your cause and your cause is
probably incorrect like your your ideas
are probably wrong and in the case of
Darrell Davis you're definitely wrong
he's not a Nazi so view shot-- shutting
that down and say these people are Nazis
well you're wrong and you're censoring
people that are trying to get to the
bottom of things and getting to the
bottom of things mean discussing things
are trying to figure out tenable
solutions or comfortable middle ground
that takes forever this is not like you
know you have Christina Hoff Sommers and
she has this discussion and and and they
pull fire alarms and and yell that she's
in nazi-like she's a feminist you guys
are crazy like this and everyone has to
comply with woke ideology 100% with no
deviance whatsoever and everyone has
take and impossible to pass purity test
it's it's this is a dumb way to
communicate you ever noticed something
too it's it's always that it's why is
the concern always that if we have this
battle of ideas that the person would
shift to the right
yes why is it why are you not concerned
about the other way right it's it's kind
of like reminds me of like cuz I grew up
pretty Evangelic of my mom was very
religious it was that she tried to it's
okay if you're if you're a good
Christian you might get corrupted by bad
ideas so we have to ban I don't know
like Harry Potter books a ban in my
household it's a way to ban all the
world because it encouraged witchcraft I
wasn't allowed to celebrate Halloween
it's pagan stuff satanic but but that's
what I mean it's like this is satanic
this is evil and it has taken on this
religious dimension this liturgical
dimension because it's well they're
always so concerned that the corruption
is just going like they're gonna drift
to the right of course they're never
concerned that that somebody might be
convinced by the arguments and go to the
left why I don't get that well the
drifting to the left first of all they
think would be a good thing the problem
no I'd only think it would happen
well they don't worry about it they're
not worried that someone would drift to
let you mean by looking at someone's
offensive views and that they would be
more likely to drift to the left is that
what you mean that like okay it's like
let's say we expose everybody to all
ideas right why are we so concerned that
that the individual that they're you
know the target I guess would be would
be shifted right and not shift it left
yeah I know you're saying yeah I think
it's they have an infantile perspective
on ideas and they're worried about
people being indoctrinated they're
worried about what they're not worried
look if you if you have someone talking
and this this person is preaching some
ridiculous thing and someone starts
becoming indoctrinated and gravitates
towards that the real problem is that
these people that are being
indoctrinated are gullible and they're
foolish that's the real problem and in
your eyes they're going in the incorrect
way this is infantilizing yes it's
actually patronizing it is
yes I think that's that's what I
couldn't
those people are dumber than you you're
smarter you know better you need to stop
these people from being tricked into
this right-wing ideology
[Applause]